welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this episode
were breaking down the new Netflix
series lock and key throughout this
video we're gonna be discussing
everything you need to know about the
new Horror Show including its overall
plot and ending there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to watch the series yet and don't
want to know what happens then I highly
suggest that you turn off now we will be
discussing what the house is and soon
elements of the comic book run so yeah
this is your last chance to turn back if
you don't want anything ruined you're
still here I just want to give a huge
thank you for clicking the video now
let's get into our breakdown of lock and
key these keys are dangerous we don't
know what they unlocked
when you suppose on the other side of
this nothing good
do we really want to know
okay so locking key is based on the
graphic novel series by Joe Hill Joe
Hill is actually Stephen King's son and
though he has some pretty big shoes to
fill in regards to his father the comic
book went on to receive critical acclaim
across the board Hollywood has been
trying to adapt this for almost a decade
now with there being several failed TV
and film projects that never got off the
ground finally though Netflix put it
into production and the series
definitely doesn't disappoint the show
masterfully follows the original 37
issue comic book run and it beautifully
brings the panels from page to screen in
a really engaging way similar to the
source material the season follows the
Locke family who after the murder of
daddy lock up sticks and moved to their
ancestral home at the key house after
little Georgie Alou I mean bode the
youngest of the family discovers a woman
known as dodging a well he begins to
learn about the workings of the property
through the information that dodge
provides the family begin to unlock the
mysteries of their new home yeah that
was terrible so what's the backstory of
the house and what is going on exactly
well luckily for you are dumped the
entire graphic novel run in my head in
the lead-up to the show
the story of blocking key dates back to
the American Revolution a group of
rebels occupying the ground discovered
that on the land existed a portal to
another dimension known as the plain of
Lang's this dimension is filled with
demons that can possess people through
touching them however if they attempt to
enter our world they collapse into piles
of whispering iron Benjamin Locke the
ancestor of the family forged these into
keys that all contain special abilities
the keys all have different attributes
to them including some that allow you to
change how you look allow you to travel
anywhere with a door that you've seen
enter your own head fix broken things
puppeteer people talk of the dead leave
your body and so on Benjamin Locke
forged these along with one known as the
Omega key which can open and close the
dimension to the other realm there's
also key that makes it so you don't have
to pay for ice cream apparently we won't
forget that one Bowie your thief the
magic of the houses spell on it so once
you become an adult
the memories start to fade but they can
creep
back in as we see throughout the series
because of this the house has been
extremely sought after by many and
though it starts off as a fun-filled
ride the sinister side of the show
slowly starts to creep in I kind of felt
that the pacing was a little slow in the
beginning and had this not had the
entire season on line from day one I
think watching it week by week would
have felt a lot worse it gets very team
drama at times which might not bother
some people but I just kind of felt like
we spent more time on that early on
rather than the more interesting aspects
of the show it takes a couple of hours
before it properly takes off but it's
definitely worth your time there's some
awesome moments in the season such as a
cameo from Tom Savini
mr. X from the x-files a trip through a
mall of memories Bodie seems determined
to lose his arm again and we learn more
about the powers of the keys as well as
the history of the house the keys
empower the kids in a lot of ways and
Kinsey is able to take the
personification of fear out of a head
tyler puts the history of Matheson in
and Bodie takes a ghostly trip to a
graveyard early on dodge tricks Bodie
into handing over the anywhere key and
this starts off a sort of rivalry
between her and the family I'm gonna be
referring to dodges that she just
because the character we see is in the
guise of a female originally dodge was a
male and then transformed into a woman
after using the transformation key and
pretty much all of the text on the story
Dodge is called the guy but yeah it's
just easier like this I will be
referring to Lucas as he even though
they're the same character it gets
confusing try bear with me throughout
the series we learn that daddy Locke
Rendell was experimenting with the keys
in 1988 and this pretty much set up the
events we see in the show with Duncan's
memories it's revealed that the group of
teenagers decided to open the door to
the realm with the Omega key in order to
trap a demon and forge more keys now in
the source material Randall's younger
brother who later grows up to become
uncle Duncan was mesmerized by the door
and began walking towards it when trying
to stop him their friend Lucas's hand
went through it and dodge was able to
touch him possess him however in the
Netflix adaptation it's a lot more
simple and Lucas is just hit by a demon
and possess
without the hero narrative that night
dodge tried to murder the group one by
one in order to get the Omega key left
with little option Rendell killed dodge
this haunted the character and seeped
into his bedtime stories and the
survivors covered up the murders and
divided the keys amongst themselves as
we know though dodge didn't die and his
spirit was brought back by Ellie using
the echo key and nurse she was able to
re-enter the world after becoming
trapped in the well dodge manipulated
Sam lesser into going to Rendell to try
and get the anywhere key this is what
caused the domino effect that led to the
character's murder and slowly set off
the chain of events that would lead to
dodge escaping from the well dodge is a
bad bad person and will do absolutely
anything to get the keys she goes
through the series hunting for them and
trying to get revenge on the remaining
survivors of the group from 88 we learn
that dodge cannot take the keys from the
locks and she must be given them and
left with little options she recruits
Sam as a helper once more and gives him
the fire key to investigate the keys
further Kinzie and her friends travel to
the sea cave to try and get to the
bottom of exactly what went on with a
father and his friends here they
discovered the black doorway and salmon
dodge make that play the former takes
the family hostage and dodge seduces
Tyler this is what happens when you lead
girls on bro ya idiot fortunately he
manages to grab the anywhere key and
back at the property Kinzie is able to
stall Sam by unleashing the
personification of a fear back at the
house
Tyler traps Sam with the head key and
explains to him that he didn't hate him
that his father kept a close eye on him
because he cared just as he has a change
of heart
dodge arrives kill Sam and takes the
majority of the keys
Sam manages to become an ethereal ghost
and we discovered that dodges been
masquerading as Lucas and lying lower
Elise using the head key dodge is able
to enter Aaron boss's mind and obtain
the location of the Omega key Aaron has
pretty much been in a vegetative state
since becoming trapped in her own mind
and Kinzie learns the truth about Lucas
and Dodge it's revealed that Rendell
actually had the Omega key within his
own head and sin
the character was killed in chromatid
this now exists within his own icky
house dodge is able to obtain the key to
the crown of Shadows and with it and the
power it possesses she unleashes an
attack on the house it's an awesome
finale that really ramps up the tension
and I loved seeing the locks used toy
lightsabers and flashlights to fend off
the dark and demonic forces they managed
to seemingly down dodge and take it to
the Omega door and send it back to our
own dimension
we seemingly get a happy ending with the
locks deciding that they found their
home at key house
and they want to remain there and
protect the objects they scatter
Randall's ashes and a new group of the
keeper of the keys is created everything
looks like it worked out well except for
one big plot thread that has been left
dangling that is where is Ellie before
we get into the rest of the video I just
want to let you know we're giving away a
free copy of dr. sleep to one random
subscriber all you have to do to be in
with the chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on lock and key in the
comment section below the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of
February in the cell be shipped out from
then Toby get surprised it's the best of
luck that everyone who takes part okay
so as we know dodge can use the
transformation key to appear differently
and with this power she can place it on
Alice we learn at the end that dodge is
not only being appearing as Lucas but
also as Kenzie's main love interest to
Gabe
don't worry Scott you're the real of
interest with this information we know
that dodge actually transformed Ellie to
look like her appeared as Gabe and then
help the group to take Ellie to the
Omega door and dumped her in the other
dimension this apparent victory has
completely lowered their God and also
made Kinsey put a huge amount of trust
in Gabe Ellie is still apparently
missing and nobody suspects that
something is up
they don't have any evidence to prove
this we also see with her that opening
the door she's brought forth an ally
with her
has infected Eden as well so there are
now two members in the camp that have
the keeper of the keys trust and after
the last strategy failed I think they'll
be playing things a lot more tactically
in the comic books Dodge's long game
actually lasted years and she
infiltrated the group by appearing as a
student so we do know dodge is still
alive and in the group and actually
playing three-dimensional chess with
them so surely she will get the key soon
right well there's actually a lot that
happens in the comics and no I think the
series may follow this I actually think
it will also divert from it in several
ways personally I think that in the next
season that Sam will discover that dodge
is Gabe and that the demon has played
the group Sam is still out there as a
ghost and though we haven't seen him
since his last appearance he is likely
still kept a close eye on everyone due
to his form at the moment he cannot warn
them but it is possible that if he steps
through the door or if say Bodhi uses
the ghost key once more they'll be able
to commune with the character in the
comics dodged ends are possessing Bodhi
at one point no I'm not gonna reveal
what happens during this arc it does
have a big impact on the series
I think Bodhi will learn the truth from
Sam and dodge will discover this and
from it be forced to come to the
forefront this is a ton of potential and
I can't wait to see what happens
and yeah it's really gripping stuff
but what did I think of the season
overall well though I did have a lot of
fun with lock and key I actually felt
the series drag that some points
especially early on and personally I
think the season could have been
shortened by quite a bit and it would
have still have hit all the same plot
points that's not to say it's bad just
there's a lot of scenes here that feel
like filler and I think had these been
removed then the show's pacing would
have felt a lot better in terms of
Netflix comic book series
I enjoyed the Umbrella Academy more but
this still had some good moments
lock-and-key was still great though and
it was good to see such a faithful
adaptation I definitely recommend
everyone gives it a shot to see if it's
for them and it gets a 7 out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on locking key in what you took
from the ending comment below and let me
know and make sure you check out our
breakdown of this week's big movie
rattling Hansel which is gonna be linked
at the end we give our thoughts on the
final scenes so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
you want to support the channel from it
so that lists 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below you
access the content early and can also
suggest video topics and breakdowns you
massively appreciate it and it goes a
long way to helping videos like this get
made you wanna come chat to us after the
show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is the channel for people
who are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
you
[Music]